hey there before we get to this week's
open and show and adam corolla i wanted
to show you a clip
of alexandria walden speaking recently
uh
representative the council of free
expression human rights at google
we have made updates to our
recommendation algorithm
so that content that's on the border
line is not
pushed out through our recommendation
system so content
that violates our guidelines our hate
speech guidelines which prohibit
anything that promotes and incites
violence against
individuals or groups or promotes hatred
against individuals or groups based on
their characteristics including
race gender ethnicity religion
all of that content is a violative of
our community guidelines
but content that's on the border is
content that we no longer include in our
recommendation algorithm
and it can also be demonetized and
comments are disabled etc
i bring this to your attention to uh
show you also this overlay that we have
with our channel
while our views retention time view time
comments interactions remain the same
our subscriber growth along with
organic search results and recommended
video
views have decreased dramatically we
have half asian lawyer bill richmond
looking into it but right now is more
important than ever if you uh can join
up at lodwithcredit.com
mug club only 69 annually for students
veterans active military not only do you
get the daily show full access to the
blaze catalog this wonderful hand edge
to mug but it's what allows this show
to continue on youtube despite the
changes now enjoy the show
louder with crowder studios protected
exclusively by walter
and hopper do not attempt the training
techniques you're about to see without
consulting a professional
tonight on crowder911 i don't think joe
biden knows what he's doing
a physically inappropriate politician
he's at the point where he gropes every
person that walks by
wreaks havoc on the lives of his voters
jump at first i thought it was cool
but then he started kissing my neck and
sniffing me
this joe biden was clearly out of
control and it was time for someone to
do something about it
[Music]
quarter person of color garrett and his
co-worker maddie have been dealing with
a politician with no respect for
boundaries or personal space
hey corner black hey what seems to be
the problem well it's
joe biden here he won't stop sniffing
and kissing people
it's a real problem yeah i've done
everything i don't know what to do okay
see
the first thing you did is right now
when you're very tense
you're giving off that energy and you
actually encourage
that behavior i encourage you that's
right
okay oh what do i do the first thing we
need you to do
is get your jawbite into a calm relaxed
state
and we're gonna do that with no talk no
touch
no eye contact okay okay that's right
all right it's okay to drop the leaf
it's okay it's okay
[Music]
it's okay it's okay okay
i see what i did is i do a small
correction
when joe biden goes in to kiss my see
i'm stopping the brain from escalating
to a state
of sexual assault that's right
i just feel bad for him i don't think
joe biden knows what he's doing my
correction
is not to hurt joe biden but just to
snap the brain out of it okay
not your track it's okay okay that's
okay
no calm assertive karma sort of hey
hey see this the corner black is giving
off a tense
energy and escalating he's asking
himself is it joe biden
going to kiss my neck is he going to
make a hair puppet and joe biden is
already
escalating his energy to match
and he's rubbing shoulders and kissing
the faces
calm assertive assertive that's it
that's right that's right you are the
alpha the path
[Music]
yes that's it okay correction correction
correct
yeah that's right because he can only
have water when you say
he can has water that's right boundaries
consistency
now you can has water you can you can
now this quarter black was doing really
good with his
joe biden so it's time to introduce a
new challenge
okay took you maddie it's okay go it's
okay
coming up on crowder911
that's not good
that's what i know
very glad to be with you my half vision
lawyer bill richman is in the house and
he was bobbing his head because he just
saw hamilton and he got a little
over-inspired
yes it was amazing the hip-hop the rap
battles it was very true
i would see it but i have a problem with
uh colonialists uh or
early settlers or founders of doing
hip-hop it's a niche problem
i've spoken to my psychologist about it
we have adam carolla on the show
today before i introduce everyone else
what was your favorite media meltdown
after today's uh press conference we
will be talking about bar and the
mueller report also next monday night
we'll be live streaming cnn town halls
uh with the democratic candidates
they're doing five
klobuchar warren sanders harris butt gig
you can pick two
okay which two comment below because i
thought it was a town hall with
everybody then i found out it was five
hours of town halls
i don't like you that much quarter black
garrett show him your hood pass
junior what's up buddy bleep right off
the bat
i love it white of the day is uh
duckhorn merlot
duckhorn the the wine dinner porn dog
merlot for you and your
is a rehearsal dinner tonight rehearsal
still not convinced that she isn't a man
uh all right we're talking about var uh
we'll also be talking about the biggest
myths well i i don't try and that's a
fair mistake to make
z are you happy i'm still not sure she
is great dear marriage partner as a man
uh leaving the news was a redacted
mueller report
uh attorney j i kept saying bob bart
bill
said that there was no evidence of trump
russia collusion here's the thing people
by the way
are accusing him already of pre-spinning
they were accusing him all day of
pre-spinning
and then the report of course was i
haven't had time to read it i'm not
going to lie to you like other hosts i
have not had time to read
it's not five pages like the green new
deal let me ask you this how do you
pre-spin a report that's going to be
released to the public in an
hour exactly come on i think everyone
out there
should watch the full conference read
the full report you want to know what i
saw when i watched this here's the thing
without reading the full report without
all of the information you can still
make a bit of an inference
here you go the department of justice
will also make the report
available to the american people in the
public report that i am releasing today
i'd leave it to his description in the
report
today i'm really focused just on the
process of releasing this report the
statements about his
his his sincere beliefs are for
are recognized in the report say what
are you trying to hide
why hasn't he brought up yet this some
sort of report
i saw him ad nauseum notify people of
and direct them to
the entire report does anyone watch the
press conference actually think barr was
trying to hide the report from the
public
by the way a report that president trump
could have invoked executive privilege
to keep from the public
so this is what i said what are we going
to say and he actively chose not to by
the way they could have had a cardboard
cutout with
saying report to be released soon right
that could have been the press
conference
looking at the macro what does this tell
you okay where are the sources for the
countless buzzfeed scene and
scandals about russia right the point is
that one side the left has repeatedly
accused the president of treason
almost never revealing their sources or
releasing evidence to the public
and right now we're seeing in response
to these accusations the trump
administration we're seeing the attorney
general willingly
hand over the full report to the public
why
because barr knows that if you listen to
the media you wouldn't read the report
your mind would already be made up
because of how long they've been
hammering you with lies just like the
green new
deal bars combating years of anonymous
sources fake stories
verifiably so by trying to ensure
there's many people's possible actually
read
the full report god forbid that count
for something crazy as far as i i see
and by the way let's be frank
president donald trump he's been cleared
legally of any wrongdoing
period it's over he's not a very
articulate man
okay i'll give you that but at a time
when words apparently don't matter where
sex is gender gender is fluid collusion
means nasty tweets semi-automatic
handgun means license three rocket
launcher
we have to give greater weight to
actions actions are what define you and
on the actions
the president has been completely
cleared in regard to collusion
or corruption or obstruction close the
books
all right your thoughts sorry i just
wanted to get that up because everyone's
what do you think about mueller and
bart i don't exactly well i mean and
that's the thing that i think we'll see
from cnn i think stelter
actually tweeted out and said no we're
going to dig into this report don't
believe what anybody is saying to you
right now listen to that's the most
masculine stealth
yeah that's true you make him sound like
brian dennehy i was trying to sound
nefarious i don't know
but i'm going to find things in this
report that would make a billy go but
here here's the thing what
really what kind of level jerk what kind
of level of
conspiracy do you have to believe in to
believe that people that did not like
trump
did this report to hide his bad actions
to hide collusion to hide obstruction of
justice from you people that don't like
him that had every motive
to come out and say he did everything
and more
let's nail him to the cross don't think
about it didn't happen like what kind of
conspiracy
theorist do you have to be to believe
that the same one who believes that
brian stelter is straight
all right now turning to ion india
[Music]
all right so this comes to us from
russia today we can't get away from the
kremlin
uh an event where cow dung is hurled by
rival indian villages to mark the war of
the married gods
this festival these people take part in
a symbolic war signifying
a mythological hindu marriage dispute
seems honoring the gods yeah where they
throw crap at each other here
what look at this seems normal right now
oh well
oh there it goes no everybody everybody
has these
okay look at that that is a lot of feces
not in the face it's like my house when
i come home an hour late from work
holy [ __ ] that one was a tide pod
in other news print technical support
was down for 14 hours that day
speaking of tide pods
[Music]
hey guys i'm about to be youtube famous
[Music]
we all make mistakes uh would make you
youtube famous i'm so glad that i have
my half asian lawyer bill richmond here
with me today not only because we're
going to be looking into the new on the
border youtube
algorithms after the show but um here's
a video
on how to beat your wife in an
islamically permissible fashion
[Music]
this is going to hurt my love for you
more than it hurts you i mean me
i mean i'm going to beat you let's be
real here let's just be honest
to be clear this is an actual video okay
we are not making this song
cleric
and by the way people get mad at me for
mispronouncing it i bet you he has the
same
difficulty pronouncing crowder
demonstrate how to punish a woman
quote uh the man is a leader in the
house a leader has authorities
just like a company are you familiar
with these legal terminologies when it
comes to domestic abuse
yes absolutely yeah frequently you hear
domestic violence
the accused uh referring to themselves
i'm merely a company manager
it's in the handbook chapter 12.
she was not following s she wasn't
following yeah it's ops and i said
follow a thing because i can't say
follow
i add the t to everything by the way we
actually uh hired a translator to
help clarify some clarify some of what
the cleric was saying
when showing your wife who is boss it is
important to remember that most women
have no
formal combat training so there is no
need to get complicated
a simple combination will suffice the
one two
or jab right straight makes it clear you
are upset
the uppercut is to explain what she did
wrong
the hook is to make sure she never does
it
again knock knock who's there
why isn't my dinner ready and i hit her
with the combo
remember a woman is not only weak but
her reaction time
is bad as well use this to your
advantage
for example i can throw blows to body
body then head this way when she
attempts to protect
her barren womb in anticipation of the
third strike
i surprise her by going upstairs it is
most important to remember
your best defense is always offensively
beating your wife
i'm so sorry my gosh i'm glad we had the
translator there look
there seems to be this sacred cow of
islam you can't
like they're beating hinduism no i know
i'm i'm blending here because of the eye
on india all right
right that's a different type of brown
people oh my gosh
would you shut up no but look i i'm
going on a trip overseas in a couple of
days you know what i'm not afraid of
oh okay no i said overseas because i
don't want to say where i'm going but
you know what i'm not afraid of
i'm not afraid of accidentally going
into a christian neighborhood and doing
something wrong and being mobbed by a
group because you're going to aruba
finally nancy pelosi
jamaica claimed this week that there is
no taint of anti-semitism in the
democratic just here's the clip
no i i because the dem we are not
and we have no taint of that
and the democratic party most shocked uh
by speaker pelosi's claim is uh
junior adviser to the minnesota
democratic party carl the anti-semitic
taint who joins us now mr tank thank you
for being here sir
glad to be with you stephen sure now
what's your response to the speaker's
comments
firstly stephen speaker pelosi has been
a dedicated leader for both our party
and our country and i thank her for it
okay the fact remains
however her comment while unintentional
was still offensive to those in the
taint community
what exactly was offensive could be
problematic of speaker pelosi's dual
loyalty
excuse me i can't blame her stephen it's
easy to be hypnotized by the media
considering who's running it
what in the pranks and all okay okay
wow so you're just going straight to the
anti-semitism uh senior advisor
there it is in record time stephen take
my comment out of context
and pit the jews against the tank no
that's not at all what's going on here
i have to say senior advisor taint first
we have omar now you it's not a great
look for the dnc
okay this is because i share the
congresswoman's concerns with the
far-right policies
of the jew government what israeli
government
okay give me one specific policy omar
and myself are not long bulls here
stephen we simply feel if the jews would
leave palestine
and as legendary journalist helen thomas
suggested go home to poland
and germany back where they were long
the world can finally heal
from all their connections you know see
this is actually this actually just
sounds straight up anti-jewish to me
color me shocked that you'd say that
considering who signs your paycheck
stevens it's all about the benjamins
right
i don't even know what i don't know what
that means this is the reason we're
involved in endless foreign wars as our
brave men and women are fighting
overseas
as vice president joe biden himself
describes them
shylock's black home are taking
advantage of them with foreclosures and
brad law
i think this interview's over it's over
yeah thank you i appreciate it
what what what'd i say it's not like i'm
claricon here steven i mean the man's a
damn cloak here
oh okay carl the senior advisor uh
that's enough that's enough they just
cut them off black carrot that's enough
thank you guys for
giving mr tate the respect he deserves
but uh we're gonna move on here to the
top
we've talked about bar there's not
enough info out there now i wanted to
get into the top socialist
lies top five myths that people um
i i guess these just continually let's
just start with this bernie sanders
town hall at fox news it personified
everything wrong
with the left wing let's start with this
uh
i happen to believe joe that we have an
absurd
tax system and while millions of people
today are paying
actually more in taxes than they
anticipated
amazon netflix and dozens of major
corporations
as a result of trump's tax bill
paid nothing in federal taxes i think
that's a disgrace
what you don't say is that everybody
paid less in taxes than they did under
obama or they would under you you piece
of [ __ ]
by the way did you notice he said dozens
of corporations
just run a quick search and see how many
corporations there are in the united
states hint it's a lot more than dozens
if we missed a couple of dozen that's
okay they're paying for
dishonesty they're paying more than they
expected because they wanted an even
bigger tax cut that you and the media
deceived them to thinking they wouldn't
even get even the new york times did an
expose on this
many people who got a tax cut didn't
actually believe that they got one at
all
most people saved money paid less in
taxes this year
the middle class benefited from the tax
cut everyone did but i bet you're paying
more than you thought
what are you saying you thought you were
gonna get a bigger price break screw you
do you remember when pelosi actually
said when they were talking about the
average being around twelve hundred
dollars per person per year
uh back in your pocket and she was like
well that's not a lot of money to most
what
a hundred dollars a month is not a lot
of money to most average americans that
you say that you represent
are you serious not the ones not the
ones that live behind walls
that can't buy a security guard at all
this is how socialism works it deceives
people into thinking they're worse off
than they are by lying to them and then
using that misery to get elected
promising to solve everyone's problem
with
free money and this was we'll get to the
top five
i think the biggest myths the most
pervasive myths all this was reiterated
there was an article this week
announcing means dot tv
did you see it's an online socialist
media network who without a hint of
irony it'll be a p
it'll be a paid subscription service
steven that's a text
so i went to their site to see what they
were about and again let me know which
socialist candidate you want us to live
stream next week starting at uh
8 pm eastern sanders harris klobuchar
butt gig warren um went to their site
means tv to see what they're no
surprises
i felt like this segment was long
overdue let's cycle through the top five
all right let's get to this
number five is that there is no class
mobility the cards are stacked against
you this comes directly from
the new paid subscription socialist
medic
you only really have like so many
positions you can go to the factory
you can go to the college or you can go
to the army
what do i have to do so i can get into a
position to where i can
change what i want to chase versus
surviving
what what oh i feel like i have no
options and you proceed to name
all the options three unbelievable
options by the way the offshoots from
those three options are probably at
least
3 000 options like i could work at a
factory
and work your way up to vice president
work your factory this was in detroit
this network where a uaw worker costs
the company average of over 130 000
a year whoa i'm going to the military
well you can get tuition paid for work
your way up to i don't know officer
not to mention serve your country oh i
got to go to college and choose
any of the hundreds of degrees available
there this is like i only got three
options
i can't do anything why are you
complaining horrible because the options
i got are only
uh infinity i don't understand
there's three options to on-ramps
basically they're three on-ramps to any
option you want for the rest of your
life
i okay this is this idea that there is
no social mobility in the united states
the cars are stacked against you
over the course of their lives 56 of
americans will find themselves in the
top 10
73 will spend at least more than a year
in the top 20
okay so this idea that there's a static
99 and top 1
ruling class it's just not true
particularly in the united states and
this brings me to myth number four that
capitalism only benefits the wealthy
uh we hear this all the time that
america sure is a rich country but
for most people it's terrible my mom
actually told me like moving to
america just like made everything worse
from where i feel the problem
i am the solution at the same time are
you high right now
you seem to be just doing worse or worse
and nobody really seems to be able to do
anything
better and better you know why do our
parents work all the time
and then it's still hard for us because
we spend too much
a system in place that keeps us there
and to find out about that system like
it's only 9.99 a month
i buy your cars i buy your car
they're not going to stay poor for long
honestly here's the no system is perfect
but name me any system throughout the
history of mankind that has pulled more
people out of poverty
than the free enterprise in a capitalist
system venezuela they killed there you
go you know what here
let's do a mental exercise everyone
watching everyone watching pick a system
any system right now think of it in your
head okay
no that's the answer let's just go
under trump because they try to they try
to amplify this with donald trump people
are worse off ever
we have the lowest unemployment rate in
50 years record numbers of workers
returning to the workforce
highest job labor force participation
rate and by the way even with all that
we actually have
both the lowest layoff rate and the
highest amount of unfulfilled meaning
available jobs
since the department of labor began
recording the statistics
ever it's time to toss your hemp noose
over the basement pipe
because i only got three options college
military or being an entrepreneur
it's like i could go to school study and
maybe like the stem field or get a shark
tank
we need a new system right well and
they're worried about people being
wealthy right they're worried about this
upper class
that controls everything right so let's
say let's say that they're right in
their socialist
utopia you know who that upper class
that controls everything is the
government do you know who's left to
oversee them
no one in this system even if the
wealthy control things you still have
the government as a check to that
strength
in their system you have nothing and
it's not even true well it could be butt
gig uh by the way
hit the note i know it's beauty
uh hit the notification bell by the way
join up at londonclutter.com it's more
necessary than ever uh half-assing later
bill richmond can tell you and of course
subscribe
and um hit the notification bell i
already said that and when it's on
itunes it doesn't really matter
here's one of the biggest ones you've
heard this a lot right the idea that
there's there's no wage growth
one of the most common myths is that
wages have remained the same
if you factor in inflation and you look
at us people are working more but
they're not getting paid any more money
here you go you hear it all the time
and about half of americans don't own a
stock a mutual fund
it means nothing to them so they'd
rather get a wage increase
for quite a while it doesn't seem to be
moving too much is wage or wages
yeah two percent the trouble with two
percent is two percent kind of just
sucks
wages that is not enough to make anyone
feel the job market boom
first if i don't want to go ad hominem
but is her chin penciled on
it's like the burger meister meister
burger has two very defined lines
okay this is just as uh problematic to
use their word as the wage gap the idea
of 77 cents in the dollar that just
compares women make x
men make why one problem with computing
wage growth the way that the bureau of
labor
the statistics do is they they do
average hourly earnings it's gonna get a
little nerdy let me try and go through
this really quickly
that doesn't take into account lifetime
wage growth i highly recommend you
check out the sources in the overlay uh
that we bring up here right now let me
distill it for you when you take into
account individual wage growth is
calculated by the census
their current population survey okay
those models it's actually closer to
five percent
average doesn't suck no average
individual wage growth is always higher
than the simple
average hourly earnings growth and
there's there are a few reasons for this
and i want you to do your own mental
exercise because anecdotal obviously
doesn't necessarily prove a point
but the empirical data i believe will
match up with your anecdotal experience
so anyone out there right now
who's done a job or been in a career in
the same field of work for more than 10
years watching right now okay i'd like
you to comment below
if you have been doing the same job or
working with the same company same field
of work for 10 years
i want you to do some math have you only
seen a 2
wage growth i i i i would
no challenge anyone out there couple
lower earners at the beginning of their
life by the way they tend to have the
most
wage growth as people get older they get
wealthier the percentage of
wage growth is less so if you're seeing
that sort of pay bump bottom out a
little bit that now it maybe used to be
10
12 now it's two percent that means
you're probably being paid pretty well
if it's over a lifetime
yeah exactly and people aren't gonna pay
you a lot more just to do the same job
if you're not acquiring new skills if
you're not making yourself more valuable
that's that's the whole point of this
the market you shouldn't wait for the
market the average hourly earnings it
doesn't take into account how long
people have stayed in a certain job i
mean imagine bill if you went to law
school
you went out and then you were a clerk
and then you decided you know what i'm
going to be a doctor and then you didn't
finish medical school and then you said
you wanted to be a shift manager
mcdonald's and then you know you
developed a heroin habit
developed that sounds exactly like his
life
here's one of the things i i kind of
frequently say is okay what is the
alternative right
it's the argument here that we should go
back to 1980s america
is 1960s america 1930s where's the place
in the past that you're saying we fell
off the train of wage growth and okay
fine let's go back to that but then by
the same out of the same mouth comes
the past was even worse it was even more
of a male
white male hierarchy minorities could
never
ever ever become president they could
never be
lawyers they could never do any there's
no mobility whatsoever so then you have
to ask the question is if over time
the policies have been coming into place
that are counterfeit directly
countervailing
wage growth right the types of policies
that you see throughout california and
are driving a huge growth
pushing californians out in every other
state it's true pretty confident there's
only one side pushing those policies
that are
pushing down the wage growth that you're
complaining and you could pull the
there were no good old days card you
know because railroads um
so good at those man by the way it's
easy to have wage growth yeah
if you just have slaves oh people making
railroads wow hey no the point is the
point is you can't
he makes a very valid point no there
were no good old days everything was
worse everyone was racist patriarchy and
like and now wage growth is worse than
ever before
your parents could buy two homes the
average home was a fraction of the size
and by the way
blacks couldn't vote see it's kind of a
big deal there's
to take some progress along with only a
five percent wage growth which is still
pretty good by the way on top of that
wage growth just hit a 10-year high
despite all the models predicting the
exact opposite uh and it seems like it's
likely to keep accelerating all right
and by the way over the last two
centuries real income has
been raised by 3 000
due to capitalism due to capitals three
thousand percent
do you have a source of the last two uh
i i'll give it to you we can put it up
later it was
over 90 000 i forgot the name of the
economist that said it was uh it was a
30 times
it's gone up 30 times of the past two
centuries was it seymour butts
was this one of those robo calls again
no because i just had a chart that
showed five percent you're like it's
three thousand over two cents listed
frankly so much weight you're gonna be
so tired of all the growth not your
wages you won't have room
your wages will have stretch marks okay
here's a second lie it's just it's
really stupid but i'm going to point out
why i think you'll realize it's stupid
on its face but you often don't think of
it this way that wealth inequality
is a huge problem we want to deal with
the grotesque level of income and wealth
inequality in america
very few people think it is acceptable
or moral that the top
one tenth of one percent owns almost as
much wealth as the bottom
90 percent here's what i call a stupid
exercise
[Laughter]
if i doubled every single person right
now watching listening doubled
all of our incomes tomorrow every single
one wealth inequality would increase
would you be pissed would you prefer to
live in a place like
cuba or venezuela where people make
whopping 30
a month in cuba the problem isn't
poverty the problem is wealth inequality
and i know that there are some nations
in between i'm not saying your only
choice is the united states or cuba
generally speaking
socialism simply socializes mediocrity
poverty
matter of fact every study that we have
available shows there's no correlation
between wealth inequality
and the poverty rate usually as wealth
inequality becomes
big as that gap becomes bigger
conditions of poor families have
actually improved yeah and part of the
the beauty of our system is there's no
ceiling
on success like there's there's no if
you want to go out there and just do
put all the time and effort in be
incredibly creative come up with
something
risk everything time fortune family
whatever you want to do
and be successful why that would that's
going to create more inequality
why would we care i want you to be as
successful as you can possibly be
i wish some of those people that were
really successful would be a little more
responsible with their money dems tend
not to give anything to charity so that
that's kind of a problem
but you know what i mean like i went
down all next week bernie sanders two
point five percent okay
uh okay so just i think earlier this
week slate.com had an article
criticizing bernie sanders response
when people were asking him about his
newfound millionaire status
right and his off-the-cuff truthful
freudian response was
well if you wrote a book two then you
could be a millionaire
so if you so if you worked hard and you
had creativity
and you put your ass on the line and you
worked really really really hard in this
system that we have right now
you too could be a millionaire just like
bernie sanders but
although really i stood on the shoulders
of the public teats
i wouldn't have been able to sell the
book if i hadn't run for
president who am i a [ __ ] rockefeller
plugin
you could say oh if you started your own
law firm you too
could be in the top 1 if you started a
show you could be in the top
10 if you started your own private
sommelier wine business you could be in
the top 10
if you were willing to forego all
security of a
salary and knowing where your next
paycheck is going to come you could also
be wealthy but in his case it was
writing a book
that only made him money because he had
become popular off of the public guy
so it's even worse than what you're
saying but yeah he's like when you write
our best i will not apologize like you
better you benefited by the way right
from donald trump's tax
but i didn't vote for it but you cashed
the
check you can pay more taxes voluntarily
at any time or you can give to charity
you don't do any of that now i
understand
say well i don't i don't want to pay
into the into the war machine system why
would i voluntarily okay
how about a soup kitchen son of a [ __ ]
i mean i don't
he gives nothing to charity wait so so
he's saying oh he doesn't want to pay a
war machine but
so during the eight years of obama
that's when he was paying extra taxes
right because
yeah that was the time because he's
gonna be the next
president and so he's saying that wait a
minute when he's president no i i didn't
even say that i was just saying you
could no no i understand but
but but the point being that that it's
always a common question right okay
go ahead yeah it's vital where does code
pink go irs will take it
whatever you want you can say no and
here's here's
you know it's not so much a lie that
they uh they they push
the here's let me set this up with a
fact socialism has never
actually worked okay and they always try
to claim that it's never been tried
properly or where it has been tried
properly now they've pivoted and this is
only the last 10 years to the
scandinavian countries that they're all
socialists here you go
what happened in venezuela they call
that democratic socialism
but it looks like he's masturbating on a
subway the problem is though brothers at
any time there's been
the attempts of ordinary people to
engage in self-determination
they can get crushed by external nation
look at u.s policies toward venezuela
has been very very ugly nicaragua in the
same way
so we've never had a chance to really
pull it off so it's only been a movement
so far well so long as we know what
democratic socialism
and if we know that in countries in
scandinavia like denmark
norway sweden they are very democratic
countries obviously
america will look more like scandinavia
that's right
that's right and what's wrong with that
uh
well there's a lot wrong with that
first off the snuffs the snus the snooze
snoop snooze if the tobacco goes up your
nose never mind
that's enough no no it's not flows in
your lip
goes up your nose news goes here snuff
goes here i don't know anything about uh
tobacco outside of cigars which by the
way ironically come from a lot of these
craphole countries oh
they tried nickel that's the one silver
lining they try to say venezuela a truly
socialist and by the way
oil-rich country kind of starting on
phase three
only failed because of u.s policies
right it actually failed because you had
something right in this case oil money
you had something propping up a horrible
system which you can do for a little
while you know what would also happen in
the
united
states you can take billionaires money
for a little while once it's gone
you're done right you've got nothing to
problem with and you're bad that is a
much more true example of socialism
than the scandinavian countries they try
to appoint yes truth is scandinavia we
did a whole segment on this so i'm just
going to
sort of brush on this skin and even
countries actually they built up their
wealth under free market
economies and right now they're actually
moving much more toward free market
capitalism
uh despite they're incredibly small
homogenous populations by the way
and keep in mind their top corporate tax
rates actually lower than the united
states were under obama we're actually
going their direction now finally for
the first time
and something else that is remarkable to
me did you know that when scandinavian
people move to the united states they
have higher standards of living on
average than those in the scandinavian
countries in other words danes in the
united states have it better than danes
in denmark
swedes of the united states have it
better than swedes in sweden
without the high suicide rate without
their surprises
well i know japan but i think norway
norway yeah that's just because of the
weather and they all have to watch let
the right one in yeah and by the way how
many times do they have to come on
camera and say bernie please stop
pointing to us as socialists
yeah we're not socialists they have a
lot of
they have a social safety net which by
the way is why cars for example most
uh i think in denmark most people can't
afford used cars you can go to lot of
credit.com we wrote an article about
this not long ago because the taxes are
unbelievable
yeah there's a huge burden on the middle
class that being said they built up
their wealth
under free market economies so you can't
claim that a country if the united
states for example tomorrow
the united states tomorrow became a
socialist country would you say that we
became the world's greatest superpower
under socialism no of course not no
absolutely not and one one final point
that i think on on just this
is social or so excuse me capitalism has
been credited over the centuries with
with saving 700 million plus lives
that's a hard number to come by i get it
i understand there's probably going to
be a lot of people that disagree with
that
but if you look at the the population
the life expectancy and a lot of the
other factors
this the we didn't have nearly as many
people and it wasn't just because
there's a lot more people having sex to
have kids it was because people could
live longer and the thing that made that
possible the thing that made it possible
for you to feed your families now
is capitalism right and it would create
a lot more success if other countries
would take capitalism and
apply that as well we've seen hundreds
of millions of people die because of
socialism they have a negative bank
balance right now or accounting
capitalism
well socialism and communism now we have
a huge positive
balance still not entirely sure what the
difference is between a marxist and a
communist i don't know i think it's the
pair of glasses which book they read who
knows
it's a haircut obviously i would say
that the facts are on our side okay
because i just listed over a dozen
but i know that both sides argue they're
on the side of truth okay let's put that
aside for a second
one thing that can't be denied is that
even in theory
capitalist free enterprises the
conservative worldview can only function
if an
individual feels empowered and i know
that bernie bros are going to say that
that's a lie because of the system man
all right i know i know the fact is that
the conservative message
is predicated on the idea that
individuals feel optimistic
about their opportunities in future
socialists can only remain in power by
convincing the entire population
of hopelessness conservatives have to
campaign on hey
anyone can make it in america you're
good enough democrats and socialists
half but i repeat myself have to
campaign on you can't make it you're not
good enough
others are going to win you'll lose and
none of it is in your control because
it's all a part of the system
it is a selfish appeal and certainly
right now in the united states it's not
based on truth right now in an economy
with the lowest unemployment highest job
participation least amount of firings
most amount of jobs available in decades
they're still selling you propaganda
that you couldn't possibly make it
without them and i'll come out and say
it
in 2019 only the weakest among you
by that lie if you look at all of the
prospects i just listed
out there and feel you don't feel
hopeful in any way
there's there's no hope for you you lost
hope long before you made that walk to
the ballot box
that's my biggest problem with socialism
all right we have to get going half
asian lawyer bill richmond
uh g morgan junior's gonna get married
next
hi this is a crowder911 telling
everybody to join
at loudouwithcutter.com and don't forget
to train your joe biden with discipline
exercise
and affection and don't forget to get
your joe biden spayed on neuter
that's right
[Music]
join mug club at loudouthcrider.com to
help us kill all the ground owls
today hi
i'm tim from hr due to the new community
guidelines at youtube
louderwood crowder would like to issue a
formal apology to the following groups
and individuals
muslims planned parenthood jehovah's
witnesses
[ __ ] also for using the word
[ __ ]
that gay guy from those vox videos
alexandria ocasio-cortez
canada
nancy pelosi subscribe to louder with
crowder on itunes and
android girls because you know you want
to bruce lee and we haven't been
demonetized there
the fat pride movement brian stelter
brian stelter's fat pride movement
[Music]
all right i'm very glad to have our next
guest on the program a lot of people
really looking forward to the next guest
people saying when are you going to have
this next guest always with the
questions
for the next guest the answer to that is
now and the reason i'm excited is uh
obviously we do a lot of the the
podcasting we do the show here on
youtube
the man here is a pioneer now he
actually held the guinness book of world
records
uh in the guinness book did you hold the
guinness book of our world let me know
most downloaded podcast i grew up
watching what the man show
cranky anchors you can follow his uh all
of his work at chassis.com c-h-a-s-s-y
dot com you can follow him on twitter at
adam corolla mr crowla thank you for
being here sir
thanks for having me i am glad i was
very nervous to have you on the show i'm
not gonna lie
i i always you know i my wife every once
in a while
says you know everyone's scared of you
and i always go
they are and she goes oh yeah and then i
go
well why do they do everything i ask
them not to do and nothing i ask them to
do if they're scared of me
so i'm always surprised but maybe maybe
people are scared i'm sorry if you are
it's no no you don't need to apologize i
think they're doing the opposite of what
you ask because your fear
uh it draws them into a place of
incompetence that's that's probably oh
why you know my assistant's in the room
[Laughter]
i'm sorry no i don't your fear has been
like a tractor beam of incompetence
yes that fear me
oh my god could you imagine if i was uh
in the military
and i just yelled at everybody your last
easy day
was yesterday and you're a maggot and
they would all
just step on landmines right exactly
they would immediately poop themselves
and step on land mines and then friendly
fire incidents
uh which we had happened when i was
being raised in canada no the reason is
i did i went out to your studio one time
and it went through some mutual contacts
and this was a long time ago
i remember back then you i don't think
you had any idea who i was you had just
restarted the show
uh love line with dr drew and i just
felt like a fish out of water
and at one point i just i ate it it was
my fault
i bombed and you looked at me like with
a look like someone disciplining someone
else's dog and i knew
i really i really suck today
well if there's any consolation i'm
still unclear as to who you are
that's no that's exactly what i said you
and many people most guests on the show
usually politicians after they appear
they say yeah you know what could you
scratch that and we say sorry it's live
to tape so before we move on
to i really want to get your opinion on
sort of the shifting landscape of
podcasts
today and and new media and i know you
have a film no safe space is coming out
you're working with dennis prager
um first off though have you been
following the mueller report that was
released today
well it's sort of like the atmosphere
or the headliner in your car like you
can't not
be exposed to it like if you're alive
and you walk upright you're over four
years of age like you're gonna hear
something about it
i don't know where to go to get the
information because i
did watch i was watching uh cnn and
msnbc this morning
and it was a lot of oh man
look out people this
and then i was listening to some talk
radio
some am talk radio and it was like
nothing to see here so i actually
thought well essentially
how are you going to get the information
if
everyone you talk to is so galvanized
everyone you listen to is so galvanized
on both sides
i did have the thought like when i was
watching cnn
when they were saying hey man
you should listen to me because there's
some serious stuff going on here i
thought
i would be more apt to listen to you
except for it's been two years of you
explaining what was going to happen and
none of it happened
right just say cnn anchors or rachel
maddow or whoever
let's just say it wasn't about russian
collusion and the mueller report
let's just say there were just someone
you knew at the track
right and you wanted to go make some
money on the ponies
and every single horse they picked every
one of their favorite
every one of their prognostications came
in last or didn't finish a race at all
right and you showed up this morning and
they were hanging out
in front of the track again yeah and
they said fan i got a hot tip for you
would you listen right i you know i had
a similar system when it came to the
electoral college and it was whatever
dick morris said
bet the opposite and i still have i've
called them all correctly no i think
that's a good point
first off it's interesting to me that
you were watching cnn msnbc
i'm a conservative i do that as well is
that a part of your daily pattern
because you want to be informed as to
what
the opposite side of the spectrum is
saying
i i am like i had a little heated
semi-heated uh twitter affair this
morning with someone who was
you know calling me whatever because i
dared to interview tucker carlson
on my podcast and i'm like hey tucker's
a good dude and you may disagree with
him but we talked about his mom and his
family of origin and i thought it was a
really good
interview and if you if you'd listen
you'd probably get a little closer to
some semblance of civility here
and the guy was like f u and f
tucker and you know sniff my fault yeah
but all right well i guess that's not
gonna work yeah well sniffing seems very
detailed but that doesn't seem so much
as a twitter call out as it is a fetish
at that point
uh it's biden asked but let's put let's
i'll put it to you this one
oh yeah he was uh doing a photo op with
kareem abdul-jabbar once and uh
there was there was some sick yeah i i
look it up look it up i ca i
i will look at it but here's just one
thing when i was talking about this
earlier of
barr he was pointing everyone to read
the report
that's one big difference i think that
you see between the left and the right
and i was watching them both today as
you were talking about listening to some
talk radio
on the left they're going oh man this
looks really bad in the report
barr was saying read the report and
people on the right seem to be saying
read the report and it's pretty
consistent across the board that's what
happened with the green new deal on this
channel i just read it
uh from from pillar to post because it
was only five pages long
if people want the information it would
be good for them to start just
reading the report but it seems like
people in media just say well you know
what take take my word for it
well you know i've sort of used
you know i have a sort of mechanical
background
and a building background and i got a
bunch of race cars and sometimes stuff
breaks on them and you have to fix them
and there's really only one approach and
that approach is
you know get get a table make sure that
tables plum and square put
the car on it and start taking
measurements and calculations and then
we're going to figure out what we're
going to do to fix it
once we get this data if you know in
your heart what's wrong with the car
before you even look at the car you're
going to be wrong
a lot and you're going to get into a lot
of accidents and you're going to lose a
lot of races so for me
this notion of like oh i already know
how this is going to play out
before i get any information it's not a
good way to go through life
if you're trying to solve any problem
and i don't care if your refrigerator
breaks down or anything to do with
politics it's just not a good way to go
and like i'm watching politically
incorrect or
a real time i should say with bill maher
the other week and
he announces defiantly he goes
i don't need to read the mueller report
i have a tv
set okay i know watching himself
yeah i thought oh wow that's uh
that's bad that's a bad place to be in
which is you're not gonna read the
two-year report
because you watch rachel maddow and you
know
what you know right and then it's at a
certain point
of moments later one of the
folks on the show on his panel said
all right i know the report said no
collusion but it's not all doom and
gloom
and i thought there's a there's an
upside here
he may be a foreign agent no i think
it's a good point if you know in your
heart something's wrong with the car
you'll get it wrong especially if you're
an angry lesbian who knows nothing about
cars
also it's ironic that bill maher's
politically incorrect was not
politically incorrect nor
is real time filmed in real time so i
don't know what to believe anymore
um let me ask you this you were one of
the earliest adopters with podcasts and
you had so much success with mainstream
uh
mainstream sort of old media fame you
know you had these television shows and
these development projects
you were on radio one of the most
listened to radio shows and then became
one of the most listened to podcasts
um in the world and in listening to you
when i was starting out people like
yourself and joe rogan i often heard you
talk about how
the great thing is there's no barrier to
entry you can reach your audience
directly
now but that was a few years ago have
you seen
a shifting landscape there and kind of
what we thought was this open form of
the internet and podcasts with
social media and youtube and twitter and
facebook and eventually itunes do you
see it as
as open as it used to be or do you see
kind of the old media guards
trying to set up new uh guards for for
things like podcasts
well i get what direction you're going
and and i agree you look everybody
if you get big enough you're gonna
become the man you know
uh zuckerberg is the man now i mean
zuckerberg didn't start that way
right woodstock you know if you want to
put on woodstock you have to pay a
10 billion licensing fee like you know
what i'm saying like there is no such
thing
as something growing and becoming as
large as
it is monetarily and in it not
becoming the demand you know so you can
think about a million companies and a
million human beings in a million
whoever
and once there's enough madison avenue
money wall street money whatever it just
you become that it and it can go no
other way
it doesn't really matter if you're
zuckerberger or starbucks like you just
eventually become the man right and so
when i started podcasting there were
two america was split into two halves
there was the half that
didn't know what a podcast was and then
there was the other half my dad was in
who called it a pod card and thought
that was cute
right so that's where it was a decade
ago
now everybody and their mother's doing
one
and you know oprah's doing a podcast
like that was that would have been
unthinkable
a few years ago wildly uninteresting but
yes there's
money involved and now that money is
involved
then everybody and the media
has become sort of the man so that's
where we are i don't
i don't really lament it in in a in a
way
like i think purists kind of go like oh
what about woodstock from 1969 or
what about podcasting from a decade ago
but it's like
it's just the way it goes it's just
progress well it's just the way it goes
i guess my concern more so and it kind
of ties into your no safe spaces
documentary you're making with prager
what we see on campus is what we're
seeing with new media
yeah if it's just business developing
but right now we see people at the top
specifically trying to
silence voices based on political point
of view that's my concern there's
obviously a market for it because there
are a lot of conservatives who want to
listen to it
um but that brings me to no sales faces
that you're working on with with dennis
prager um when can we be expecting that
and what has been your experience as a
as a long-time comedian now
on college campuses does it make you
want to blow your brains out as it often
does uh myself
yeah i'm going to need to borrow your
t-shirt later today so i could just head
to
yes well i think you'd be better off
borrowing my 3d printer that would that
would help you more but yeah
okay um so
a couple things first i do have a
stand-up special called
not taco bell material which uh i think
your audience would enjoy and that
is out now so people can enjoy that
uh itunes and amazon and chassis and
everything else
the working with prager's great because
i
he he he's he's such it's such a weird
thing it's so weird when you know
dennis prager personally and then you
read
how you know he's homophobic and
xenophobic and islamophobic and he's
like he's the most gregarious
oversized jewish uncle you've ever
met and he loves to laugh and he just
he's infectious with his attitude like i
wish i was in
as good a mood as he's in all the time
um
so we've had a chance to tour around and
play do some college campuses
and it's getting pretty pretty crazy out
there
and look there is no
i guess what i'm saying is this i have
twins
and uh they're gonna be 13 in a few
months and
i i'm going out on the road this weekend
uh cobb's comedy club by the way san
francisco a couple tickets left
okay and i want to take my two twins out
to dinner
tonight before i go on the road and i
thought
oh i'd like to eat at this chinese food
place by my house it's good chinese food
and then i paused and i thought oh i
know they're going to complain about it
because they don't want chinese food and
then i went what and then i went
huh and then i went wait a minute
when i grew up if we went out to dinner
once a year it was a big deal
and the notion that you had a vote in
where you're going to eat when your dad
said come on we're going to taylor
steakhouse you want look i'm not in the
mood for that old man
i want sushi that's unthinkable except
for
it's the new norm now if i say to my two
kids
hey we're going out for chinese they'll
go one will yell i want
sushi and the other yell i want surf and
turf and my thing is is
what was unthinkable is where we're at
and if you go to the college campuses
today and you hear what these 18 and 19
year olds have to say for themselves
what was you know uh we're going to
uh protest because of the vietnam war
or nixon or watergate or kent state or
whatever it is
from we went from that to
ben shapiro is not welcome anywhere near
this campus
we went from what was the norm to
unthinkable and it's not their fault
it's just like my kids it's not their
fault we've ruined them
yeah well you know in my experience it's
been
it's been not the student body but the
people in charge academia professors and
the students who write the deans the
people who make sure that you don't get
on campus we just did one at ut
we didn't even announce it hunt there
were hundreds of kids just doing this
this changed my mind where we sit down
and just talk about an issue completely
unedited
it goes against every rule in the media
book right it's long
it's boring it's not polished and kids
wanted to uh to hear the conversations
but there was one girl who tried to
steal a maga hat off someone's head and
literally said unironically that she was
triggered she didn't
have any sense of self but i didn't want
to we have to get going not talk about
material as a stand-up special
um i i wanted to to ask you why did you
do a stand-up special
now because i know you've been doing
stand-up for a long time um
and some some people some stand-ups
never do a special and i thought you
might be one of those guys who just
wanted to keep it in the clubs
and then i saw uh that this was out
there
uh it's just i have so many things i do
in a way it's not a great
uh career move to play you know
15 sports sort of thing i look at comedy
as like
saying athletic you know athleticism
yeah but you got to pick a sport
and you're much better off just kind of
doing one thing and not the other and
i've just done
everything and i enjoy it
and i thought but i've never done a
stand-up special and
i i just i guess there's a feeling of
you want to capture it you go out
all these years you develop all this
material
and it just floats up into the ether at
the end of the show at the end of the
evening at the end of the night
so i just thought let's capture it
and also i'd like to get paid
yeah that's a good reason too let's put
that in column b it's at
chassis.com and very funny by the way i
think a lot of people who haven't
watched your stand-up will will enjoy it
a lot
i remember talking with people um about
your stand-up and then going like yeah a
lot of people don't know that adam
cola's stand-up is is really tight it's
really funny stuff because again i grew
up watching you on tv and
in canada you know we don't we're not in
the land of really cool stuff so we
didn't have access to a lot of the
content you did in the united states i
had two pirate crank yankers
uh on a dvd burner yeah back from an old
hp uh desktop so uh
yeah and actually my wife and i that was
when i realized i had a sense of humor
we watched cranky anchors we said
first when i first moved to the states
at 18 the first comedian i saw was jim
florentine
at the improv because of crank yankers
and i remember him mentioning you in
your stand up
you know it's funny they say imitation
is the sincerest form of flattery but
really
piracy is the sincerest form of platter
if you think about
it right yeah it is for a show that
sucks
it was a fantastic show piracy is a the
highest form of flattery tell that to
metallica
maybe it'll cheer them up that in a few
hundred million dollars all right we do
have to get going
chassis.com adam krull thank you so much
for being here sir
uh we appreciate it and uh we'll talk to
you sometime soon
thanks dan all right we'll be back after
[Music]
this
[Applause]
so what happened i thought we were
talking about facts
one other fact that i wanted to share
with you is about uh
you know so many facts readers digest in
the 1970s
made a point to really sensationalize
the notion
of the so informed you won't need to
factor
that's really bad for
middle-aged business find the aging
turks live
weekdays from 6 to 8 p.m eastern
watch them before they die
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stop playing games with your personal
protection try the walther today
you see what i did there with the stop
playing games
walter's happy about it hey guys quick
uh one live route of the week it's not
to tell you about mug club because i
already have or walther because you've
already likely purchased them if not you
should be ashamed of yourself it's to
tell you that next
week monday uh cnn is hosting five
live town halls and so we will be live
streaming their live stream
uh from seven i think seventies to eight
depending when we start
five candidates club jar warren sanders
harris
butt kig you can pick two depending how
it goes maybe we'll do the rest of the
town halls on monday
comment below let me know which ones you
want to see most and we'll be there with
a live stream and drinking game rules to
follow
[Music]
[Music]
sorry i uh i it's one of those days it's
been pretty tough to yeah
to do that just not sorry guys for
giving me uh not doing the drowning
dance though
i think this is the first time in in
four years um
i know that often in this this last
segment you know the team is bringing it
crowder closes i talk about things that
um hopefully matter to you hopefully
means something to you
uh and are hopefully helpful and and i
um
and i try to be honest with you as
honest as possible
uh vulnerable when appropriate um
but there's there's been something it's
been a tough
it's been a hard week and it's hard to
um
there's something that's been bothering
me for a while that haven't really uh i
haven't
i've talked about it but not to the
severity of
i actually i think that um i think that
probably my feelings could
best be put uh into a song
[Music]
hey my my
[Music]
instead of the skies
the burrowing owl has got to
[Music]
die
instead of the skies you live in the
fields
[Music]
you hiss at me yeah you're such a [ __ ]
ever heard a property rise
your little prayer
[Music]
put you six feet under beneath the film
[Music]
i want you to extend your little strange
bird
[Music]
if i can't have that i'll take in danger
i want you wiped out
and gone for good
i want you extinct but i'll take in
danger
[Music]
hey my mind
[Music]
the crown hour has got to
die
[Music]
you live in the dirt
[Applause]
instead of the skies
[Music]
yeah the ground out you've got to
die
[Music]
you